cuz I was just melted with an anxiety
decimated with it and by the way my
parents are still married my mom's a
brilliant Professor my wife loved me
most of the time I had a healthy kid
like I had no business on paper having
anxiety what if this anxiety what if the
ADHD which the body's response to chaos
what if fatigue your body's like hate
and we're going to wrap it up into
something that you will digest which is
sleep let's just go to bed we think of
fighting and fleeing we think of fleeing
as running and screaming fleeing is
often just turning Netflix on turn it
kind of quiet and get under the covers
right and so I'm somebody who begin to
work backwards what is anxiety doing in
your body and in your brain oh dude this
just trying to get our Attention our
bodies are working pretty damn well so I
have to ask a way harder question which
is not Hey how do I shut this alarm
system off but what is happening in my
life to set this alarm off